que l'on peut dire c'est qu'il ya eu des
réactions plutôt contrastée dans cette
cour à l'issue du discours du président
de la république un discours dont la
tonalité direct a été constatée 1 par la
plupart des personnes qu'ils y assistent
et qui a plu à plusieurs agriculteurs à
qui nous avons pu parler qui ont salué
bien son expression franche et son bon
diagnostic c'est le cas de maxime
guérineau qui était éleveur de volailles
en écoutant le rendez vous avec monsieur
macron très bonne réaction
on voit que c'est quelqu'un qui a eu une
bonne analyse de la situation
aucun problème de filière équine en est
conscient maintenant on va avoir un
petit peu comment est-ce qu'il va
résoudre tous ces problèmes pas d'acteur
entre autres les gros les gros
distributeurs ou les moules et les
personnes qui y gagnent pas mal d'argent
autour de nous maintenant voilà c'est on
est con on est content d'avoir une
personne comme lui qui a vu qui a vu ses
problèmes la croix malgré cela malgré ce
ton très direct et malgré le caractère
très accueillante à cette entrevue et
bien emmanuel macron n'a pas convaincu
tout le monde a notamment sur le fond
sur la question du mercosur cet accord
de libre échange qui inquiète beaucoup
d'éleveurs notamment d'éleveurs de
boeufs de viande
beaucoup d'agriculteurs on le sait ont
manifesté hier pour redire leur
opposition et bien tout à l'heure on a
pu également entendre un éleveur de deux
vaches un éleveur un producteur de lait
et de fromages qui nous a confié que là
dessus il n'était pas du tout convaincu
mais il nous a réconfortés à peu près un
peu sur la viande
nous ce qui nous inquiète le plus c'est
moi personnellement c'était la qualité
de la viande qu'ils allaient être
apportées on nous aurait comporté en
nous disant que
il les fait réalisable et faire
attention et puis les consommateurs le
choix surtout de faire attention un peu
acheté cette viande et nous voulons
maintenant on espère enfin certains
autres personnes que nous avons bien
interrogeant estimé que le discours des
manuels macrom d'arras tél de belles
paroles et que eux continuent à attendre
les actes certains nous ont confié leurs
difficultés personnelles nous disant
notamment qu'il avait pu constater bien
la dégradation de leurs conditions d'une
génération à l'autre d'agriculteurs
écouter tout ce qu'on entend aux infos
tous qui dit faux que la réagissent faut
que je réagisse
voilà les coûts de production augmentent
et ont promis à 30 ans mes parents
exploitaient il vendait de la viande et
du lait ils vont elles mêmes prix que
cette année qu'en 2018 entend donc que
les coûts de production et des sphinx il
faut moins élevé bref malgré cette
opération séduction à l'égard de près de
mille agriculteurs aujourd'hui bien il
n'est pas certain qu emmanuel macron ne
soit pas un chahutée lors de cette
visite qui s'annonce longue samedi au
salon de l'agriculture